we're told Ryan and Sabrina are running
a race Ryan runs three miles every 17
minutes and we see that right over here
this is Ryan after 17 minutes he's run
three miles and Sabrina runs five miles
over 29 minutes and we see it right over
here after 29 minutes she has run five
miles the tables below show each of
their distance over time who runs at a
faster rate Ryan or Sabrina so these are
hard to compare directly three miles
every 17 minutes versus five miles over
29 minutes so what you want to do is
find a point on this table where the
where the ratios between time and
distance are easier to compare and the
easiest ones to compare are when you
have the same numerator or you have the
same denominator so let's see over here
are there any points at which the
numerators are the same or the
denominators are the same well it looks
like over here it took Ryan 85 minutes
to go 15 miles and it looks like I took
Sabrina 87 minutes to go 15 miles
so it took Sabrina two more minutes to
go 15 miles so she is clearly a little
bit slower Ryan's a little bit faster so
Ryan runs at a faster rate let's check
our answer let's do one more of these
these are a lot of fun the following
table shows equivalent fractions to 9
over 100 fair enough the table shows
equivalent fractions to 99 over a
thousand and then they ask us which
fraction is greater nine over 100 or 99
over a thousand and this set actually is
not so hard to compare even without the
tables you could multiply the numerator
and the denominator here by a thousand
and yoour by a ten and you would get 90
over a thousand and comparing that to 99
over a thousand and 90 over a thousand
is clearly smaller so you could say that
that nine over 100 is less than 90 99
over a thousand but another way to do it
is to look at the tables and so look at
a point where you have the same where
you have the same numerator or
denominator and you see that 9 over a
thousand is the same thing as 450 over
5000 and 99 over
is the same thing as 495 over 5000 so
you have the same numerator and each and
you get the same denominator
but this numerator is larger 99 over a
thousand is a larger number and we mark
that right over there